you need to keep in mind when you are we
had a look at this okay we did the best
we could and what we're looking for is
an understanding of the general behavior
here there's gonna be lots of crazy
features here that we're not gonna
expect you to work yeah you can sort of
always judge that by having marks there
are no question okay you'll notice the
first thing that I did or maybe you
didn't notice that until you looked up
just there is that my axes go a lot
higher and lower than the range of my
components let me say that again my axes
go a lot higher and lower than the range
of my components the range of my
components is negative 3 to 3 and
negative 4 to 4 why did I draw it so
high and low yeah very good if I'm going
to be adding these things right
well the biggest list could be is 3 the
biggest this can be used for so
potentially it's actually not trying
true it's gonna be a bit long but
potentially I don't really know they
could hit 7 at some point so that's why
I've drawn it that high and the same
thing for the bottom okay so that's why
I've got the range that I do now I have
to have a think about what's going on
now there's some easy points you can go
to you it will help you out firstly are
there any discontinuities that's kind of
where it started
no no just the discontinuities these
guys exists for all real values of fear
so just go on forever okay fine over
here what was the next thing I did not
answer identified the discontinuities
where do I go next yeah I went from
points like that I would've moved like
this because they were easy to find
and then I just kind of worked out the
rest of the pieces okay I guess in
terminology you know when you do a
jigsaw puzzle right generally we do the
edges first because they're easy to
identify they got straight pieces and
then you kind of fill in the gaps
we haven't the same thing here okay so
what are the edges one of the easy bits
well ordinates what ordinates are easy X
feed up rather they don't say 2 equals 0
what are the ordinance for both graphs 0
so you're plus 0
zero okay in fact there are two other
places where both ordinates are zero
where are they at PI and at two pi which
is a relief because you can see this
thing is periodic every two pi radians
that's right
this is periodic every PI radians so
therefore by the time I get to 2 pi I
better be back where I started
okay that's good there are actually
other places on the graph that I notice
for instance this guy bug the one that's
wiggling around faster do you notice
he's zero there the ordinate is zero
right so if you've got zero plus
something else
zero plus something else is something
else right now by the way I actually
happen to know the exact value in this
case it's it's for isn't it cuz look
look at the crap read this guy who has
gone through half the cycle that's why
he the zero this guy has gone through a
quarter of a cycle so he's at his first
stationary point see that and the same
thing happens but in Reverse over here
see that zero plus and negative
something is going to be a negative
something okay okay good we're starting
to get some shape here this is good I
can see this kind of thing happening
what else
now can I perform Steiner feelings and
more difficult grams okay so I can look
for some intersections right now you can
literally this is what we expect you to
do again like I said in an exam
situation you might often be given these
graphs so you know they're to scale and
that's helpful right you can actually
measure some things right you can
measure this distance right maybe it on
your page it's like two point four
centimeters and I like that
well if you're adding the ornaments then
you're going to be four point eight
double that alright and you're gonna put
that out now what I'm gonna find is if
you have a look here you can see these
guys are both positive so you're gonna
be up high and you're gonna be somewhere
like this right now I am actually gonna
draw that a bit lower I know I'm never
gonna get to seven can you see how I can
tell I never
yet to seven okay in order that's
perfectly which in order to get a seven
out of these this has to be three and
this happens to be four I guess I could
say I want both heels to line up exactly
and they never do do that right like
this guy is a bit off from this guy and
in Reverse this one is off from this one
okay so it's going to go up but not as
far okay
so I'm gonna go up like this you can see
this is actually super steam what about
the graph tells you that this part
should be really steep
yeah fantastic you've both got steep
gradients both of the components so
you're not actually going you're moving
forward from thinking about just the
values to how are these grass behaving
okay
so then you go up you're gonna have to
come back down again because you've got
to get down to this point right okay now
look again what's going on
I know I've got to get to 0 and I've got
to get to 0 however it looks to me that
somewhere between here and here see how
this is positive right and this is
negative at some point I expect that
this should be opposite to each other
right one will be the same amount of
positive as the other one is negative so
I'm expecting somewhere in here this
should be another point of intersection
now I don't expect you to get it exactly
that's fine but get your roll around get
your roll around and look at you will
find a rough point at which these are
roughly equal to each other these
distances right I'm gonna place it
roughly there ok now what is happening
in between
hmm have a look let's just look at this
little patch here ok do you see this guy
is positive begin long
this guy is negative and getting lower
right which one is happening faster
now when I say faster I guess one I'm
trying to hold maybe I should define
language I'm asking that which one is a
steeper gradient gradient now because of
the numbers here it's a bit hard to see
but actually I would probably conclude
this guy has a steeper gradient can you
see why right um tree grass they get
steeper gradient when you push them
together right because if I make this
something ridiculous and extreme like 20
feet up right you're gonna get this
right it's gonna go up and down up and
down so it's super steep right now this
is pretty close but look this 3 3 signs
we did is twice as frequent right so
therefore you're getting this drop it's
dropping down because this guy is
dragging down faster than this one is
pulling on but then in here it reverses
so it's gonna actually come back up like
that now that was actually the hard part
because now the rest of it just replays
in Reverse replacement reverse for
example can you see what's happening
over here do you see it pretty much
exactly symmetrical to this guy over
here yes
in fact I want you to imagine this this
is hard to I'm gonna call
I don't want you doing read don't put
this on your diagram because it will get
very messy but I want you to imagine it
with me I want you to imagine but the
y-axis was there instead just just
picture that now I want you to look at
each of the graphs see this for sine
theta write this for sine theta has a
particular kind of symmetry around y
equals x can you see what the symmetry
is it's a it's rotational symmetry can
you see that you can take this part and
you can rotate it around to this pot
what about 3 sine 2 theta
what kind of symmetry does it have it
has the same symmetry it has exactly the
same symfony right there's the 3 sine 2
theta I can take that pot and spin it
around and I'll get the same thing so
you can get two things that have
rotational symmetry and you put them
together you just get a new thing which
has the same rotational symmetry ok so
this shape that you just worked out over
here all you have to do is spin it
around and you'll get the same one over
here so let's draw that it'll look like
this ok it is a weed shape but I'll
start setting it oh yeah I missed just
you get the idea ok so yeah it's kind of
cool one of these one of the conclusions
you draw from this is what you learned
in auxilary angle Dubois very angle
right this sum of any two we call these
wave functions not very original name
it's waving around the Sun of any wave
functions is a new wave function that's
in to find out what the rest of the
graph looks like it's periodic so this
is just gonna start all over again from
over there so make sense